there's three stages
that a covert narcissist operates in and
the first one is
love bombing so in order to recognize
that there's a covert narcissist in your
midst
anybody that just over the top love
bombs you
uh they are interested in everything
you're interested in they want to be
with you they
rush to the relationship stage right
away
watch out watch out because that love
bombing
will bring you in like a black widow
spider will pull you into that web
have you ever heard a woman say that i
want to glue myself to you
because she always wants to be around uh
actions sometimes say that too
you got to be careful be careful because
uh that is a
huge red flag and that's the first stage
that love bombing
and it feels good especially if you
haven't been with someone in a while
and you want to be with a woman that's
where it gets most guys right because
they're not particularly or or highly
successful on the suction marketplace
and it's like all of a sudden
somebody shows up out of the blue that
just like gets them
and just loves them for who they are or
so they think
exactly exactly so uh that
first stage love bombing watch out don't
get roped in
uh and then of course the second stage
is devaluation which we'll talk about
and then the discard
but uh in order to answer your question
um
some of the traits you're gonna see in
these folks is there one is they're
overly competitive
they're jealous uh she might say
something to you like
did you see what rita got for
valentine's day from doug
what did you get me what are you what
have you gotten me lately i mean
that's unhealthy and um that's a
narcissistic kind of mindset
one other thing just a general statement
uh paul's right these folks are hollow
inside i liken them
to the chocolate easter bunny where they
look really good on the outside but on
the inside they're hollow
they're afraid they're fragile they're
nasty and you don't find out sometimes
until it's too late
so the goal is get your radar up and
listen and observe
that's your best friend in this case um
another thing is just overly concerned
with their appearance
hair extensions a ton of makeup
you know that's not necessarily
indicative of having narcissistic
personality disorder people put
themselves together pretty well
but if they're over the top about it get
a closer look
and make sure that there's not other
things that would indicate narcissistic
personality disorder
um they're materialistic they're all
about what you drive
that prada or gucci handbag um
that is another indicator
that there could be narcissistic
personality disorder
one humongous indicator is they have a
superiority complex
everything they have everything they do
every trip they take
is better than yours better than
everybody else's they only care about
appearances
um they never like live in the moment
they're all worried about
how can i curate a photo to put on my
social media so everybody sees me
in this pose uh that's a pretty good
indicator
uh not any one thing in and of itself
will define a narcissistic uh person
but in aggregate they start to add up
and
you're getting a good sense that you
could be in a bad situation
um people uh who have narcissistic
personality disorder will think that
everyone's
jealous of them that uh you know it's
like grandiose and that's like an
outward sign
so be aware of that and you're listening
and you're
observing as time goes by you're
spending money uh
time and with someone uh and dating them
narcissists especially covert
narcissists uh
overly critical to any criticism you may
have of them no matter how minor
they blow up even if it's an innocent
thing
but boy can they dish it out during the
devaluation stage
they'll tell you they don't like
everything about you
but if you dare respond in kind and say
anything negative that could be a
construed is critical
they blow up beyond belief that's a
something to really watch out for um
she's a drama queen all right um i don't
know about you guys but i'm pretty sure
you don't have any room for drama you
know there's enough drama out there
there's a ton of drama in my life in my
work life but i don't tolerate any
outside of it
nobody should uh it just creates stress
you'll never be the best version
of yourself you don't need it so if
somebody's all about drama
or you they manufacturer drama
get a close look and observe um
they like to do what's known as
triangulation
where they'll pit family members and
friends against each other
they incorporate what's known as flying
monkeys on their side
to try to bad mouth you or look at you
in a bad light
that's a huge red flag not only is that
immature
but that is indicative of covert
narcissistic
personality uh so be careful of that you
don't want to get tangled up with that
because it's just a matter of time until
she triangulates people against you
and badmouths you so watch what they do
um
covert narcissist shameless disregard
for boundaries
uh she could do whatever she wants shows
up late
says uh she's gonna do something no
follow-up but god forbid
you do and all hell breaks loose
you don't want to deal with somebody
like that uh they
practice what's known as gaslighting
where they have you
uh wonder whether or not you're really
in touch with reality
you could have a conversation with them
an
hour ago and they'll deny ever having it
or deny saying what they said you almost
want to record them
and play it back and say yes you did you
said exactly that
so it's known as gaslighting it's a
horrible tactic
that narcissists seem to be pretty good
at don't fall for it
don't force stand firm uh it doesn't get
better
i just want to add to your point on
over competition and jealousy um you
made the point of like you know rita got
uh such-and-such from a husband what did
you get me
um i also call that when she when she
compares
um somebody else's best to your worst
right meaning like well you know jeff
doesn't leave his socks on the floor
so why do i have to pick up your socks
right
but jeff makes like no money compared to
what you bring to the table sort of
thing like that's
that's somebody that's that's like
really flicking boogers at you from an
unnecessary place
right you know what i mean
you